Ahsoka was born on the planet Chile in
36 BBY she was discovered by Jedi Master
plokun at the age of three in 22 BBY
when the Clone Wars broke out between
the Republic and the separatists Ahsoka
was assigned as a Padawan to Anakin
Skywalker by Jedi Master Yoda in 21 BBY
ahsoko was part of a mission to
investigate a mysterious distress signal
in the craylethium system there she and
her companions encountered three
powerful force wielders the Father the
Son and the daughter in 20 BBY ahsoka's
life took a dark turn when she was
framed for a bombing at the Jedi Temple
AFI was revealed to be behind the
attacks as part of her plan to expose
the corruption of the Jedi and the
Republic Ahsoka was cleared of all
charges but decided to leave the order
and walk away from her life as a Jedi in
the year 19 BBY Ahsoka was contacted by
Boca tan Crees Boca tan asked Ahsoka to
help her liberate Mandalore from Darth
Maul Ahsoka agreed to join bocatan's
cause Ahsoka led the assault on Maul's
base in tsundari where she confronted
Maul in a fierce duel however before she
could deliver mall to Coruscant Order 66
was executed by Chancellor Palpatine